[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace 25 años
mientras muchos de ustedes nacían
nací a mi hijo mi primer hijo felipe
nacida con una pequeñita diferencia
nacía con un cromosoma además un
cromosoma 21 demás nacida con síndrome
de edad
esta pequeñita diferencia y va a ser un
grandísimo impacto
y el primer impacto se los voy a
compartir
un sentimiento inmenso de temor
de miedo
tal vez de miedo hacia lo incierto
hacia lo desconocido
de hecho como muchos de ustedes estaba
terminando mi formación como pediatra y
tenía mis próximos 50 años ya
organizados planeados
la llegada de mi hijo iba a implicar
romper todos esos planes desbaratar ese
castillo y volver a empezar
eso da miedo
lo que se venía la incertidumbre
y en ese momento tenía dos opciones o
miraba de frente de ese temor
o me paralizaba
y probablemente octava por otras
opciones que les confieso pasaron por mi
mente rechazo darlo en adopción
pero decidí mirarlo de frente
y aquí se los presentó
era este pequeñito que pesaba 3 kilos
absolutamente indefenso entonces la
pregunta es
porque me generaba ese temor tan grande
parecía que él me estuviera diciendo
mamá cuál es tu problema si es solo un
cromosoma además sin embargo yo estaba
muerta del pánico
en ese momento tampoco sabía que más de
mil a tres mil
millones de personas en el mundo cifra
que viene en aumento
estaban compartiendo conmigo en sus
familias
una persona miembro con discapacidad
y vienen en aumento porque finalmente la
población está envejeciendo y tarde o
temprano todos vamos a necesitar un
apoyo o un caminador o un audífono
entonces tenemos que empezar a cambiar
la idea de que la discapacidad es un
problema sólo de algunos
yo decidí
mirarlo y mirarlo de frente
nuestros niños también son una población
grande como nos contaba
el doctor restrepo
y mi primera manera de mirarlo de verlo
fue la lactancia era como una pulsión
como un instinto que peleaba con todas
las demás
eran sentimientos casi que primitivos
desconocidos para uno hasta ese momento
yo no sabía que iba a tener tantos
sentimientos desconocidos para mí pero
este primaba un instinto de tener que
alimentarlo y fue a través de la
lactancia que yo aprendí a mirarme a mi
hijo a los ojos
y no quedarme mirándole los ojos
esa mirada que seguramente había
aprendido también muchas veces en los
libros en las clases de genética
entonces en ese momento para mí como
mamá fue un gran reto dejar un poco lo
que había leído en los libros y empezar
me acercar a él ese fue nuestro primero
encuentro pasó un año dos años con esas
inquietudes y temores siempre de mamá
pero cada vez más liviana será que
camina será que no camina será que
aprende a hablar será que aprende algo
es un poco más liviana pero todavía
llevaba mucho peso y les voy a compartir
un episodio de la vida
como a sus 2 años felipe cuando íbamos a
tierra caliente le encantaba levantarse
la camiseta y echarse en el piso como un
sapito a sentir el fresco del piso
helado
mi labor como madre era corregirlo era
decirle que no lo hiciera que se deseaba
el deber ser
a esos dos años en esos dos años en
alguna ocasión yo decidí que más bien lo
que tenía que hacer era yo levantarme la
camisa y acostarme al lado de él para
sentir lo que él estaba sintiendo para
entender cuál era ese frescor que él
sentía al acostarse como sapito en el
piso frío
en ese tipo todavía no hablaba
pero me volteó a mirar y con una sonrisa
inmensa me quiso decir oye mamá por fin
me entiendes
y entonces entendí en ese momento que
era yo quien debía cruzar la orilla
y me empecé a liberar empecé a sentir
que se me quitaban una cantidad de
cadenas empecé a sentir como felipe me
ponía alas
y empecé a entender que un cromosoma
además no le restaba nada al contrario
de su mamá
le sumaba es la humanidad que nos hace
falta a tantos
entonces fue mucho más más fácil seguir
con el seguir ese camino ya me sentía
mucho más libre mucho más tranquila
orgullosa de salir a la calle con él
pasaron 15 años
15 años de lucha de caminos recorridos
con dificultad sobre todo en nuestro
país cuando les cuento que casi menos
del 2% de 10 millones de personas
matriculadas
o casi
menos del 2% de jóvenes con discapacidad
con todas las condiciones pueden
ingresar al sistema educativo formal
sin embargo
[Música]
sin embargo recorrimos ese camino
a sus 15 años entonces ese camino aún
no del todo pavimentado en nuestro país
tenía una inmensa pregunta una inmensa
duda y después que después para donde si
se acaba la escolaridad a dónde vamos de
nuevo a las casas no entonces decidimos
encontrarnos con unas familias que
teníamos también hijos en condición de
discapacidad
y decidir que así no hubiese sino un
abismo al final de ese camino y vamos a
construir camino y ese camino era donde
debían estar los muchachos al finalizar
su escolaridad media 17 18 años debían
estar en la universidad
entonces fue este tercer encuentro
encontrarnos con otros saber desde ese
momento que solos no podíamos hacer
camino que teníamos que juntarnos
teníamos que unirnos pero sobre todo
teníamos que quitarnos a nuestros hijos
como una carga de los hombros y ponerlos
como parte de nosotros a construir con
ellos un camino y un futuro
fue así como en el 2009 nació la
corporación transición es crecer con el
sueño de abrir camino donde no existía
en esa época aplicamos entonces a un
proyecto de investigación en la facultad
de medicina y ciencias de la salud
planteando un programa innovador de
inclusión para jóvenes con discapacidad
intelectual en la facultad de medicina y
ciencias de la salud y él está ya es el
estar allí tenía un sentido muy
importante en relación a lo que decía el
doctor restrepo los médicos
y el sector salud en general tenemos que
aprender a cambiar las miradas y que
mejor que cambiar miradas que en los
espacios de la universidad porque es en
la universidad donde se construyen
mundos posibles es en la universidad
donde se sueña es en la universidad
donde todos tenemos la oportunidad de
encontrarnos con la mayor diversidad en
todas sus formas en todas sus
expresiones entonces qué mejor libro que
estos muchachos
estén compartiendo esos espacios
lo que sucede en las aulas en la
universidad es muy importante pero lo
que más importa es lo que sucede fuera
de las aulas cuando nos encontramos con
los otros y esos otros entre más
diversos sean más representativos son de
lo que es el mundo que otra
manifestación de la diversidad que el
ser humano
fue así como este proyecto se fue
concretando y tuvimos la inmensa
posibilidad de que ya saliera de la
facultad de medicina y se expandiera a
toda la universidad con todo el apoyo de
la rectoría vicerrectoría y dirección de
estudiantes
hoy es un sueño hecho realidad es un
camino que se está construyendo
y por eso estamos acá
aprendiendo y compartiendo con ellos
hace un año
tuvimos la oportunidad de
forjar otro encuentro maravilloso y fue
el encuentro con el papa
francisco que vino a trabajar el tema de
encuentros desde el acuerdo de paz
y los jóvenes le brindaron un mensaje y
unas palabras
que básicamente lo vamos a resumir
como el encuentro
con la vulnerabilidad
porque finalmente la vulnerabilidad es
lo que nos hace humanos
es el encuentro mucho más real desde la
fortaleza de la vulnerabilidad que de la
fragilidad de la perfección que
finalmente no existe
entonces tenemos que encontrarnos en esa
vulnerabilidad que finalmente es la
esencia de lo humano
y por eso voy a aprovechar estamos en
este espacio maravilloso para invitar a
los muchachos que pasen aquí al frente
les voy a presentar los protagonistas
reales de esta historia para que
compartan con ustedes unas palabras
línea maría
felipe
digo silvana paula si cabemos todos
correcto
queremos un
queremos un mundo inteligente para
celebrar nos los unos a los otros como
seres humanos todos diferentes como
manifestación de la vida y su diversidad
que queremos un mundo en el que la
vulnerabilidad sea reconocida como
esencia del humano que lejos de
debilitarnos nos fortalece y significa
un lugar de encuentro común que nos
humaniza
este fue el mensaje que los jóvenes le
dieron hace un año al papá y es el
mensaje que queremos dejar hoy en esta
inmensa oportunidad de encontrarnos de
cruzar orillas y de construir un mundo
posible donde todos aportamos y todos
aprendemos de todos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]